non ma fille costard de stars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
qui sait
c'est alain chamfort
et puis son nom mais je le connais je le
connais je le connais je le connaître je
le connais qui s arrêter aux enfants
daniel
balavoine
je le connais ce petit ce petit jeune
jeu
jeune mais ça c'est beaucoup plus jeune
mais il n'a pas tellement changé oui
savez qui c'est oui tu vois comment il
s'appelle à ottawa
adam ans je n'ai pas ça dans
pourquoi
appel après l'accident de voiture
visage il a eu un accident de voiture il
ya six mois
merci maintenant il est comme ça oh là
là c'est sûr que les
je veux bien mais c'est bien il va bien
c'est trop baissé c'est via vous le
trouvez plus beau maintenant ou avant de
venir
dites lui parce qu'il vous regarde et
dit adamo vous êtes très beau maintenant
comme ça avec lui oui c'est vous êtes
autre bon maintenant c'est bon chance
merci adamo
cherche je cherche je cherche je cherche
son nom tellement les gens temps
modernes lui il est pas beau d'air
madame il est ringard c'est pas son nom
de star
oui mais j'y arrive pas je l'avalé vous
connaissez bien bien non mais je les ai
connus
j'aime trouve rien y connaître alors
non non non j'ai vu le trouver
c'est papa c'est pas peur
c'est ton papa fin
ce papa
enfin
michel
zhai fut
[Applaudissements]
postale store pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu